this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
so I've been hanging around Stanford
campus since I was a kid there may even
still be bookcases in the Dean of
engineering office that I built when I
was in high school or something when I
was working for the one of the one of
the labs over there and but when I went
off to undergrad I went to Oregon State
University great program there in
mechanical engineering but one of the
things they didn't do very well at the
time I don't know if it's changed I hope
so was there was not a lot of hands-on
work in the shops and labs and that sort
of thing so I ended up having to get a
art minor just to get my hands dirty so
I I did a couple of years doing metal
smithing and jewelry work as as part of
my undergrad and then when I got out of
school I went off to to Lockheed which
if I had learned my lesson from
undergrad about getting my hands dirty I
wouldn't have gone there because I spent
the next 10 years doing simulation and
analysis work and giving presentations
at the Strategic Defense Command in
Huntsville Alabama and places like that
for long time and I missed that so much
that I eventually abandoned that career
completely and came back to Stanford to
to make stuff because I really enjoy
making stuff so with that a couple of
years ago I was asked by the science
teacher at our grade school to give a oh
ok now i really need to pay attention to
what i'm doing here the science teacher
at our local grade school asked me to
give a little quick talk at the science
fair
so I did that
kemah computer now we don't have an
aspect ratio problem oh alright hold on
we'll fix this yeah I have an aspect
ratio problem with this mismatch between
yeah maybe he's got if he's got any
thoughts I should have done this before
hand obviously what do you think well
let's take care of it yep you what's the
native for that one it's 20 x 960 okay
cross our fingers
oh my god how many of you actually are
not coming up
it's not happy
which I t get out of there goes okay
this is the i remember when i was at
lockheed all those years that the
standard for presentations in the like
was view foils on a few foil projector
and the only thing that ever went wrong
was the bulbs always burned out and it's
still not coming up hmm yeah please ah
there we go that's fair yes okay let's
try that is my other car which does not
classify as a fuel-efficient vehicle
yeah there we go now I actually have to
yes lovely mouse get it oh come on right
after this some talk I'm taking this
computer to I actually am 20 it's coming
back to the III it wanting to default on
to the wrong screen big E's bears lair
displays yeah and now it's not letting
me even ha good grief my favorite okay
that's going back to a single display
well we should also ask has anybody who
want to do a repo cash for climate not
fun
keeps showing up showing up great on my
screen so I can give this whole talk you
just won't get you just won't get to see
it is all oh and I got a cursor back
that's a sign it's doing its its it so i
spent about 10 years of lockheed doing a
ballistic ille ballistic defense stuff
and then came back to stanford to do a
couple years in the graduate program in
the design program which was awesome I
had so much fun and when I left here I
spent a couple of years working for a
company down Los Angeles wet design may
have heard of them they actually were
founded by another Stanford grad who did
the product design program mark fuller
because he really liked fountains and
water so I spent two years down there
working on ah genius mm-hmm yes a hand
for that man okay great and then after a
couple years working on fountains the
one that was really memorable most of my
time there was spent working on the
Bellagio fountain which I'm sure you've
all seen in every television or movie
always seems to start if it happens in
Las Vegas starts with a shot of that and
then I went off to Xerox PARC where I
worked on robots well so this photo was
taken in the loft space the old design
loft space that is by the mechanical
engineering shops when I was working on
a light sculpture back in the mid-90s
and one of my projects for my graduate
actually this was more like avoidance of
working on my projects I was supposed to
be working on I made an ice cream maker
and this is a couple of projects that i
did as part of that master's thesis work
on cups
I just did an exploration do a bunch of
different cups this is this is hand
raised silver and an elf you've any of
you ever seen this kind of work before
you start with flat sheet metal and you
start hammering on it and eventually you
raise up this form which can then be
this case soldered to a lost wax cast
stem and polished and all that sort of
thing and then these were I was really
proud of the use of actually recently
these are sort of stemless stemware
which I've noticed over the last couple
of years have actually been in stores I
can say that I actually built some back
in 1995 I didn't make any money off that
though so this is not this was the T
said I did when I was in undergrad when
I was trying to get my hands dirty and
avoiding my mechanical engineering
homework this was the Bellagio fountain
when it was when there was no water in
the lake so this lake is about 10 or 12
acres this would be sort of the opposite
of the environmental project because
this thing's consumes massive amounts of
energy right it's got three megawatts of
light fixtures in it and it spins all of
its time pumping water into an arid
environment right so maybe not the most
environmentally conscientious thing to
be working on it's very cool it mean
it's an awesome display but when you
start thinking about the stuff
underneath it you just got to shake your
head the other project i work on at
after i went out was at school was this
robotics project that was also a great
fun and when i got out of grad school I
got done with working at the fountain
company I went off to work at Xerox
proud Xerox PARC where we were working
on these modular self reconfiguring
robots these were these were a blast
very very cool and interesting
projects lots of opportunities in that
space and robotics for for our future
the one that comes to mind today just
because of my involvement with Tesla is
the self driving automobiles the impact
that will have on on our lives and our
environment in time will be I think will
be really dramatic not just for the for
the lives saved but also there's great
opportunities for increases in
efficiency and that sort of thing you
know imagine you're going to Grand
Canyon for the for your weekend or
you're over your week off or something
like that and you can just sort of crawl
into the back of your car and snuggle
into your pillow and sleeping bag and
tell it to get there around eight
o'clock in the morning and stop for
coffee when we get there please and you
only have to drive 25 miles an hour
which is the maximum efficiency speed so
you can save a lot of energy on the way
so this is sort of the work that i did
before i started at tesla these robots
these actually they actually did stuff
each one of these little robot modules
were the same so they could all sort of
not each do very much but you put them
together in different configurations and
they can do interesting things oh and
this one I think this never works for me
so if it would have worked today I would
have really been stunned
ah see here oh now my other folder got
shut off so courtesy of our computer
issues i'll work with my
ever have those days where you worked
out way too hard the day before and then
you went out drinking late and then you
had to get up early the next morning
this guy it's a slow process but the
beauty of robots is that nobody has to
watch right we watch them because
they're interesting to watch but for the
most part they can just do their own
thing and take as long as they need to
because eventually the job will get done
those were those were a blast all right
so that's where I've been let's talk
about where I am
so this is actually my favorite slide in
the whole presentation it's not mine of
course Lawrence Livermore has been
cranking these out I hope you've seen
these because this slide before actually
because it's one that it has so much I
mean Edward Tufte with love this slide
right it just has so much information on
it and tells all kinds of different
stories in it one of the stories it
tells is what we do with 24
transportation how do we get from place
to place what do we use to get there
there's really only one thing we use
petroleum fuels that's it there's a
little bit of you know some other stuff
biodiesel and natural gas and biomass
but for the most part it's all petroleum
and in fact it's very hard to do
anything but right fuels are just such
an efficient carrier of energy that is
very difficult to do anything else in
the transportation sector except use
some sort of fuel the other thing that's
the other story in this chart is about
how efficient these processes are right
so you look at the back side of this now
they've just made an assumption down
here about the efficiencies of various
processes so they're probably ought to
be error bars around all these things
this chart assumes that the fuel use in
transportation is twenty five percent
efficient I think that's sounds like a
good number every time I've gone out and
looked those are the kinds of numbers
you see it's hard to do better than that
because there are so many constraints on
an engine in a car right it has to fit
into a certain volume and has to fit
into a certain weight it has to fit into
a certain cost in order for it to work
as a as a prime mover for a vehicle that
you know efficiency is only one piece of
that total puzzle right if you look up
at the time
though in the electricity generation
there's a couple things you one is that
there's any number of fuels will work
for that sector you can generate
electricity with almost anything and the
processes for generating electricity
from a fuel for instance are inherently
more efficient why because that's really
the only thing they have to focus on
aside from I mean obviously there's
emissions and all that sort of thing but
they don't have weight constraints they
don't have to lug these things around
cost constraints are much looser just
because you've got a power plant that's
going to sit there for potentially
decades cranking out energy and since
the primary cost of goods sold to a
power plant is the fuel that fuels it
you want to use as little of it as
possible so there's a huge incentive for
them to make that processes efficient so
if you can divert some of this
electricity down here and your
transportation you've accomplished a
couple of things one is you've reduced
your dependence on this one particular
class of fuels and you put yourself in a
space where you can do something more
efficient because you can separate the
operation of that vehicle from the
efficiency of the power generation
you're using to drive it so but there
are course challenges but before we get
to those talk a little bit more of this
so start with a gallon and a half of
gasoline why gal and a half because
that's roughly equivalent to 56 kilowatt
hours which is the amount of power and a
Tesla Roadster battery pack which right
off the bat tells you a whole nother
story right five dollar gas can with a
little bit of gas in it weighs this much
56 kilowatt hour battery pack thats you
know really big and costs tens of
thousands of dollars so there's clearly
some work to be done there but this
thing of course is used over and over
and over
again and the efficiency of the process
in the electric vehicle is very high
conversion from battery through drive
electronics into motor out two wheels is
in this kind of eighty percent class
whereas for a gallon of gasoline most of
it goes out of the tailpipe the rest of
it goes to your wheels so just looking
at the sort of carbon footprint and and
dependency on petroleum fuels even the
most efficient vehicles you know in this
class are are using obviously using oil
using gasoline their emissions are
generally higher partially now this is
actually maybe the plus side of
expensive battery packs if battery packs
were cheap you wouldn't necessarily care
how big or efficient the car was in
terms of how much energy it takes to
push it through space but because
battery packs are expensive there's
actually a really strong motivation to
make them as small as possible which
pushes you to reduce the drag reduce the
weight make your car as efficient as it
possibly can be so that by the time you
do put that expensive battery pack in it
it can be as small as possible so here
are some comparisons of right so we've
been talked about sort of how efficient
the car is from taking power in the
battery to the wheels well okay but that
doesn't really tell the whole story of
getting that fuel to the power station
through the power station through your
electric transmission lines into your
car when you take it all together and
just do what they call the well
two-wheel energy calculation which I
presume a lot of you have seen before
something like the the Roadster any and
actually really any all
vehicle is going to fall fall over and
in this category maybe not as great as
the road stereos but they're going to be
over there just because of the
efficiency of getting power from a power
station as opposed to generating it
yourself in your car and the drive to
make the electric vehicles as kind of
efficient as they can be for the for the
payload they've got to carry to keep
costs down so where are those costs
coming from well right now they they
come from two categories and those both
of which have huge opportunities to
change the biggest contributor is the
actual cell itself turns out and I don't
really understand the whole story but
I'm guessing that the all the laptops in
our laps and on our desks here have
driven the development of this
particular cell this lithium-ion 18 650
is 18 millimeters in diameter 65
millimeters long it's a single cell that
gives three point seven volts or
whatever it is nominal and anywhere from
you know a few watt hours maybe up to as
many as 10 10 watt hours or something
like that they are for your money the
best deal in town except for lead acid
but i think the everybody right there is
not a single car out there except if you
go to a sort of obscure
build-it-yourself site that uses lead
acid battery packs for four vehicles the
only vehicles around that use those are
forklifts and they use them because they
needed ballast weight anyway so putting
a thousand pounds of battery on the back
of this thing just to hold it down as a
good thing and they don't
also for the dollar they deliver a lot
of power but lithia these lithium-ion
cells are the next best thing or
actually well they're certainly the best
thing in terms of for vehicle use the
other the other big cost of course to a
battery pack is all the ancillary stuff
so when you take a bunch of these cells
and put them together lithium-ion cells
they need to be monitored you want to
make sure they're balanced you know you
take a stack of cells our battery packs
in the Model S for instance is close to
400 volts it has almost a hundred
hundred bricks we call them in series to
stack up to give you that 400 volts you
want to make sure that none of those
little bricks get out of whack that for
some reason if there's some maybe one of
the cells has got a little bit of a
short circuit in it or something like
that in it slowly draining off the power
in that one little brick for those all
those little cells in parallel how to
monitor the voltage on that each one of
those bricks so you've got 100 bricks
well then you're going to need a hundred
voltage sensors keeping track of all
that stuff these things are sensitive to
temperature we've all heard stories
about them even in laptops but in other
places as well going into thermal
runaway so you want to monitor their
temperature you want to watch them even
your right reach our jable hand tools
have you know three leads on every
battery pack 24 the actual charging and
a third 12 for the little temperature
sensor that's in there to monitor their
temperature so there's there's lots of
management that happens so inside you
know inside a roadster battery pack or a
Tesla battery pack there's a what they
call a battle battle battle battery
management system board one board that
kind of takes responsibility for the
whole pack and then there's another
board for every one of these modules and
it has all the little temperature and
voltage sensing lines going out and
actually that architecture is not unique
to Tesla
most everybody who's building these days
it's great you can see lots of people
who you know cut open battery packs and
look what's inside and post videos on
YouTube and so you can go look at and
see how everybody else has solved this
problem and they're all sort of solving
it in the same ways they have a BMS
board to take care of the whole thing
and then these little BM bees that that
monitor individual modules people use
different approaches for cooling some of
them are some of the packs are very low
density and they blow air through them
to keep the temperature down we use
liquid cooling circulate coolant
basically like the fluid in your
radiator through the pack to keep them
cool organ I shouldn't say not just keep
them cool to maintain their temperature
this case is where we actually heat them
up because they have a preferred
temperature operating range if you live
in Minnesota or Alaska leave your car
out overnight it's actually more
efficient to waste some of the energy in
the battery pack to heat the whole thing
up so that you can use the the heated
pack up for for driving and there's you
know there's news it seems like every
week about another new battery
technology and how their people are
moving forward in this is tons of room
for growth in this area there's also
tons of room for growth in this space
and the enclosures and the management
systems for all that a lot of lots of
work to be done some examples of cells
that are out there we've measured you
know if there's somebody out there
making in 18 650 we've put it on our
testers and and run it to see where it
falls in terms of energy density and you
can see there you know they're averaging
about 200 watt hours per kilogram 200
watt hours per kilogram so what does
that mean in terms of a pack so when you
take packs and this is I don't know if
this is even a real number I mean we
talked about this number people
sometimes talk about these numbers and
compare but but in reality
if there was any kind of competition
around pack power energy density then it
would stop mattering because people
would arbitrarily move things in and out
of the packs because you can do that
it's mostly its structure its
electronics its cooling system it's dead
space but these packs all run in this
you know so you've gone from a cell at
200 watt hours per kilogram to a pack
which is something you know order of
half that the Model S's is in that sort
of 140 class so it's high partially it's
high because its large right the bigger
you get the less the overhead is for a
given size so the Model S is a big 85
kilowatt-hour pack so it has a higher
densities and a lot of these smaller
ones do okay so kind of all this work
right figured out that you could build
an electric car it's going to do all the
stuff but you got to sell it on the
market what's it going to cost so if you
start with you know one of these cars
and then you make some admittedly gross
assumptions right this is back at the
envelopes lot of stuff you say well
lights guess that maybe sixty percent of
the purchase price of the car is
everything but all the stuff i would
take out if i was going to convert it
over and then i'm going to put back this
other stuff of which the battery pack is
by far the biggest component let's
assume that it's six hundred dollars per
kilowatt hour now you take a car take
one of your cars the compact the sedan
your sports car that is a space price of
one of these numbers assume that your
car can go for miles for every kilowatt
hour you're paying 600 bucks per
kilowatt hour battery pack that's 150
month one hundred and fifty dollars on
your purchase price
every mile that you can drive that car
and then you can see really obviously
why the nissan leaf for instance has a
short range right you would not take a
fifteen thousand dollar car and put in a
fifty-thousand-dollar battery pack
nobody would buy it right it's kind of
like buying a 100 million dollar house
that's on a hundred dollar piece of
property you just you know something
something wrong about that equation and
so as you move up and the asunder you
understand then the motivation for Tesla
getting started at this really high end
because at the time they started they
probably couldn't have even produced a
battery pack for this cost much less
made any money selling a small number of
vehicles for twenty thousand dollars p
so they started way down here you know
in a hundred thousand dollar range but
it also shows you that what happens over
time is well if the more you can drop
that cost the more those battery packs
and electric vehicles make sense at a
four or more common less expensive
vehicles so here's some you know some
examples so if you start at four hundred
and fifty dollars per kilowatt hour a
battery pack well then your battery pack
is just going to cost a lot and in fact
this number is close to what the model s
I think if you go online and look at the
model s battery or go online at the
month Tesla website they actually show
you the purchase price of the car with
either the 85 kilowatt hour the 60
kilowatt hour or the 40 kilowatt hour
battery pack and it's like a
twenty-thousand-dollar difference for 45
kilowatt hours of power which is not
that number but it's something in that
I'm getting my numbers mixed up but I
believe this number is close to what the
Model S is and this is similar to what
the model s range is
44 miles per kilowatt hour so if you buy
the one that has 300 mile range you're
probably spending you know close to 35
thousand dollars on the battery pack but
as you develop cars as you develop
better technology sorry for the
batteries and bring this cost down to
300 or 150 then all of a sudden these
numbers start coming way down very
quickly and they make a huge difference
to the purchase price of the vehicle and
make make those make those cars a
reality so the folks who founded Tesla
did all that and decided to start a car
company this was their first mule I'm
even I was trying to even look up what
this vehicle was I'm not even sure what
it is but it's it's why I'm sure they'd
glad they didn't go to market with that
yeah it's the load the the one that they
actually used for the roadster is very
similar to the Lotus Elise doesn't look
a lot like any sort of looks like this
but hoey oh that's interesting thought
maybe that's where they got that anyway
that one had some great properties too
so they built their first mule they got
into the business they had I think you
know company was founded almost on this
decision what what cell right and if you
think about if you're going to found a
company or start something big the first
thing you got to do is that fundamental
back-of-the-envelope question answer
that fundamental question on the back of
the envelope around the you know around
a beer with your buddies is does this
make sense and what would you use to
make it all happen and this is the crux
of that right selecting the battery is
sort of the first thing that you got to
do
because you're going to bet the whole
company on that technology our old
building in San Carlos making stuff you
know hook or by crook you know coffee on
the top of the stove and melting who
knows what in the bottom epoxy potting
or something like that the first team of
that mule and then they kind of got you
know demonstrated they could do it
figured out how it was going to be what
it was going to look like and then they
got seriously into the design of the
Roadster oh so this does address some
important things though so battery packs
are expensive so you're really
incentivized to keep that vehicle
lightweight and aerodynamic so some of
the two ways that you do that right off
the bat are you do an aluminum chassis
and a carbon-fiber body the Model S is
all aluminum it's an aluminum body with
some aluminum substructure under
undercarriage and that's sort of
fundamental to that's one of the ways in
which electrics tend to be different
there's a lot of impetus to make
internal combustion engine vehicles
lightweight as well but the lever just
isn't is strong right it's not pushing
as hard to bring those things down has
this big battery pack right behind the
seats power electronics module and then
the motor and drive train in the back
I've driven these a few times I once we
were trying to put some high vibration
kind of miles on one that we've made
some changes to and so a bunch of us
were driving this one car every day
twice a day somebody was making a trip
from from Palo Alto to boulder creek by
going up page mill skyline highway 92
china grade road which
is if you've ever driven on it is this
sort of one-and-a-half lane road full of
potholes and it's just nasty it was I
almost got car sick and I was driving
and it just the whole cart was rattling
the entire time but it survives a trip
just fine and boy it just corners like a
dream and when you decide you want to
pass somebody you think about it and
then then you wondered where they went
you know it's like wow oh that's those
lights in the rearview mirror very fast
so in 2006 they unveiled the Roadster in
santa monica big excitement there got
some stars to show up and i think it's a
lot prettier than the first mule they
build it's very fast not a huge top
speed and i think that's really because
it's it's only got one speed there's no
gearbox right you got a ton of torque
when you put your foot down but but then
the motor just basically tops out it
does it will do 240 miles on a charge
which is which at the time was and still
today really is is a pretty high bar
there's not a lot other vehicles doing
that I think the model s may be the only
one and if you ever you ever get a
chance to look this up on Wikipedia
because you'll probably be out there
buying cars sometime and you'll want to
understand what the heck MPGe actually
means and you have to look it up to
understand it because if I tried to
explain it i'm sure i would get it wrong
but basically it's it's telling you how
far you could go on the equivalent of
the equivalent energy in a gallon of gas
so if a normal car would go 30 miles on
a gallon of gas if it were an electric
vehicle it would
probably have about four times that just
because the gas engine is about one
quarter of the efficiency of taking
power off battery and but you sort of
have to look at the details to
understand that as your omissions you're
a gas obviously so he started delivering
in 2008 I heard this story that when
they started and it's much like it is
today the Fremont factory the realities
of actually building cars right so if
you build a car and it's got five or ten
thousand parts in it every one of those
parts has a purpose right otherwise it
wouldn't be there which means that you
can't ship it unless every one of those
parts is in there we saw this you know
last year right with the with the
earthquake and stuff and in Japan right
the company on the planet that makes
door latches for everybody went down and
every car company in the world basically
came to a stop for a few weeks because
nobody had any door latches there's only
one company that makes them and and they
were out of commission same thing
happens to us not door latches but you
know any number of things anytime
something is not working it means that
cars start building up in the shop or in
the parking lot or wherever until that
thing gets resolved and then they can
fix them and send them out the door in
the very beginning I there was a story
about you know you on must coming into
the factory and seeing 30 cars parked
inside not shipping to customers and
this was the first batch that was going
out and tearing his hair out and telling
everybody to get to work and figure out
what the heck's going wrong and get
these things out the door it just takes
a lot of work to build a car there's
just too many parts ryland time frame
that the Roadster started shipping
because it was getting a lot of press a
lot of attention Tesla started getting
contracts to do powertrain parts for
other companies so Mercedes was one of
them
and so they started building the
electric you don't know whether it's
just the battery pack or whether there's
something more in there I'm not familiar
with that program but the least the
battery pack in the in Smart TV is is
Tesla part 2009 they unveiled the Model
S that's when I started in February 2009
so the first thing I started on was and
I work and that worked in the battery
pack organizations so first thing I
started working on was the battery pack
for the Model S we got this do a loan
guarantee we got investment from day
Mueller we got a contract with them for
four batteries for the a-class know if
you've seen those around their cute
little cars 2010's with a big deal
they've been struggling with where to
build the model s for a long time they
had a couple of different possibilities
and then with the relationship with
Toyota happened now turned out that the
president of Toyota was not a fan of
electric cars he had made a statement
like within a year of this relationship
saying toyota is never going to build an
all-electric cuz this is a dumb idea and
then apparently either we took a car to
japan or he came over and was in town or
something I suspect somebody flew a car
to Japan and took him for a drive in the
Roadster and he got out of the car was
like smiling ear to ear and was like
okay where do we start it was really an
eye-opening experience and in fact after
this investment happened the Fremont
factory was owned by Toyota at that time
GM Toyota had owned it coned it and then
GM had abandoned Toyota had it so we we
picked it up for a song by by Bay Area
property price standards
and then started working on the rav4 EV
there's a we've got this great I'm shop
at that the Deer Creek facilities nearby
here and big big open floor and it
always just seems to have this random
assortment of vehicles in it that have
either been built from scratch or
converted to electric and there have
been a lot of these rav4 is around which
has been great they're very cool in fact
I've heard that of all Toyotas cars not
quite sure if this is right it's either
it's either first or second but this is
the fastest car that Toyota halves in
terms of acceleration of all their
vehicles I don't think so so last year
finished the Roadster production so
that's done and and started building the
beta fleet so we've done several
iterations of cars right like anything
you're going to prototype test the heck
out of it refine the design build
another one except when you build a car
it just takes a whole lot more effort to
build a prototype than and I ever would
have imagined you know you think about
stamping a body panel like big sheet
metal panels how are you going to build
a prototype one of those and yet they do
there are companies in the course in the
Detroit area that specialize in doing
this kind of stuff and just as an aside
that particular technology is they take
this there's some alloy of zinc and ten
and aluminum or something I it's called
Curt site and it's a fairly low melting
temperature very kind of brittle and
stiff but because it's such a low
melting temperature it's easy to recover
so they pour out and has very low shrink
ray so they can pour huge blocks this
stuff machine a shape into it
damp out a few hundred body panels and
then melt it down and all the shavings
that went with it and start over again
so you actually can stamp out these big
pieces of stuff this factory I'm always
stunned when I look because I have to
figure out how to get there sometimes
and where I'm going its enormous this
picture doesn't do it justice because
this line of stuff on the right-hand
side those are the train tracks it was
like 14 or a dozen parallel tracks over
here it's got almost the same amount of
train tracks as San Francisco does
coming to feels like it's a huge
facility inside this 5 million square
feet of space and when it was first
available to us and we were no kind of
wandering around exploring it felt like
a movie set for some post-apocalyptic
disaster movie I mean was just this
horrible scary place you ride your
bicycle around with your flashlight
hoping you didn't fall into a any number
and you want of the number of giant open
pits you know where there's some giant
stamping press had been that they
removed and so these are all these
little things down here are all semi
tractor-trailers and parking lots full
of cars and but a lot of production gets
all the assembly gets done here a lot of
production gets done here all the
stamping presses for bodies lots of
injection molded for big parts like
bumpers right it's just one big plastic
piece for a bumper skin it's happening
in here so here's some of the here's one
of the presses I think this is the one
you know this press can stamp out a
piece of sheet metal that's 20 feet long
or 15 feet long or something like that
and I think they bought this in Detroit
from somebody who didn't need it anymore
and they shipped it out it's like a
hundred train car loads of stuff you
know I don't know how many empty million
pounds of of material but there
just bang parts out it's really amazing
to watch so here's this is door these
are doors door panels you can see the
cutout for the door handle a couple
years ago none of this existed this all
new and it's it's just amazing boggles
my mind to watch all these robots um
moving around doing all this stuff it's
great I haven't been watching my time
well good perfect anyway it's all very
cool to watch it's great to see people
are excited working on these because
they really feel like they're part of
something that's very new there's some
definitely some new technologies I mean
there's lots of new technology in the
car that are just sort of car related
stuff but some of the challenges
Manufacturing a car in aluminum it's
just a very different mindset than
designing a car out of steel forms
different there's different things you
can do with it you're going to extrude
aluminum you can't really do that with
steel you can easy to cast aluminum so
it changes changes what the parts end up
looking light as us you know similar
structure in the rear end of the to the
roadster the power electronics now the
power electronics are sort of a
cylindrical module that connects to the
battery packs they all go together and
then the battery pack sits down flat
underneath the rest of the car the Parts
I designed or are the plug of the socket
really on the back of the battery pack
and the plug that's in the car that
connects the two so on every time they
put a battery pack into the car I cross
my fingers and cringe it's occasionally
goes badly and when it does people get
really upset because they're sort of
towards the end right and now my fault
that the production has stopped it's
very very disconcerting
beautiful car I actually haven't ridden
in the finished one the only one I ever
wrote in I think it you'd had a
windshield but I don't think it had side
windows or much of the interior in it
and I wrote in it it actually it got
motor trends Car of the Year yesterday
and it got automobile magazine's Car of
the Year a couple weeks ago and I think
they've all said sort of the same thing
that the body is yeah it's nice is sort
of what you'd expect out of a high-end
luxury sedan but it's really when you
start driving the thing that you just
get kind of wild by the feel of it so if
any of you are car buffs it's funny I
didn't appreciate it when I went to work
at Tesla but most of the people there
are sort of car buffs in some way or
another they may not really it's not
like every car in the parking lot is
some wacky thing but there's a lot of
them and then a lot of people who are
there just they just really like cars
and so they know everybody loves getting
an getting opportunity to drive one of
these really fun there's a test track at
the new me facility so you can actually
go around us with a high banked corners
and all that stuff which is very cool
well scary the first time and go around
but and so seats five in the kind of
normal two and three and then in the
back and the under the hatch in the back
there's actually these two little car
seats for small people and you can order
it with either the 160 2 30 or three
hundred mile driving range it's
expensive they suggest that for all the
reasons that I talked about in the
beginning and that's really where the
opportunities are for the future you
know the goal of this company was to to
really make the point and drive it home
hard that an electric car could be a
real car that
people would enjoy driving right and the
Roadster convinced a lot of people that
that was the case even in you know even
presidents of car companies that that
was the real deal so the next step is to
move move down the chain to something a
little bit more common still it's a
high-end luxury car but after that will
come the next one in the next one and
and hopefully this will start you know
start the Avalanche where all the other
companies will get involved I've heard
Ilan say you know he's not out there to
beat everybody he's happy to beat
everybody but what he wants is not for
us to be the only game in town for
electrics but really for this just to be
the starting point for for electrics
we've recently unveiled the Model X and
we're working on the Mercedes b-class so
Mercedes is going gung-ho on the stuff
toyota is doing it as well and this we
have this new supercharger network which
is one of the questions i think somebody
submitted here's the b-class model x
looks a lot like the model essex of
color so it's sort of SUV ish these what
do we call these there they're not that
we don't call them gull wings though
they had another name for him it's like
the hawk wing or I'm going to getting it
wrong I can't remember because I haven't
seen one of these actually since the
unveiling but these are actually not the
front doors that do this as it's the
rear doors that do that the front doors
or conventional so the kids in the
backseat of the ones who get the really
cool unique experience anyway Falcon
thank you I knew there was a um this
supercharger network was just unveiled
we're starting with
facilities in California so these little
circles are your you know Oh what range
is that I should be able to guess that
from the scale of the map must be a
couple hundred miles so California will
be well covered and what you get with
the supercharger is to say oh yeah 150
miles of range in 30 minutes so one of
the advantages of these lithium-ion
cells especially compared to like let
acid or or anything really anything else
is that you can charge them quickly you
can push them hard and as long as you
watch their temperature and stuff you
really can put a lot into them you can't
take them all the way up to full charge
right because at the end if you look at
the charging profile for these cells and
I think almost all batteries are this
way the closer you get to 100% full the
more you have to sort of paper often and
slow down so start in California and
then you know cover the whole country
eventually somebody will be I don't know
who I I heard somebody had already done
the coast to coast drive in their model
ass since they bought it somehow I don't
know how they you know where they
plugged in to do that but they did it
and when the supercharger network gets
really completed you'll be able to do
that faster Joe so that's one of the
ways that that and these this kind of
the supercharging thing is i would guess
this is something that's sort of here to
stay right if you're going to put a
hundred two hundred kilowatt hours into
a car that's a boatload of energy so
even if so even if the battery
technology is actually the more the
battery technology gets better means the
faster you'll be able to charge it
and the more capacity it will have so
these kind of supercharging things where
you need to be able to dump a lot of
energy into them quickly is only going
to increase you're never going to be
able to do this I I can't imagine you'd
ever be able to do this at home right i
mean you think about how much power you
put into your tank at a gas station it's
like a megawatt you know it's it you're
sitting there porn gas in but it's like
a megawatt going in there at that rate
it's just it's a huge amount of energy
that's going to your tank yes sir oh so
there is a company right across the
street from us better place that had
talked about doing that and i gotta say
that this is my personal bias no way and
the reason i say that is not because
it's not possible it's because it's not
I say it because I don't personally
believe that it's practical that getting
a bunch of car companies actually
getting a bunch of any companies to
agree to a standard form for a battery
pack such that you could remove and
replace it quickly just sounds to me
like I can't even imagine trying to
organize that you know having that first
meeting about hey let's do it this way I
want to do it my way this is going to be
beta x VHS x three quarter inch you know
it just seems to me like a very
difficult problem you come up with a
form factor that people could sort of
kind of all go with like maybe something
smaller than the full battery pack like
a like a module where some cars might
use to some might use six whatever and
that they were somehow i know attached
to the bed car in a way that you could
really get them on and off easily there
might there might be a way to make that
happen but i I just
across it swallows hey yes even Tesla
couldn't do that they could do it across
model x and model s because they they in
fact will use the same battery pack and
we have demonstrated now I mean I say
this there's no way partially you know
my job is bended to develop the plug and
socket between the battery and the and
the car right and that is something you
can just push together you shove a
battery pack in there it's connected you
don't have to most almost every other
electric vehicle on the planet that's
ever been built has a cables going into
the battery pack and some sort of bolted
joint somebody's got to get in there
with a wrench and hook those things
together the Model S is the first car I
believe that actually just uses a plug
and socket similar to what you're you
know your laptop charger uses it's big
it's about this big around it's got two
big blades that are you know an inch
wide and an eighth of an inch thick so
that part you can do you can do the
quick connection for the pipe our the
low power signal because I did both of
those and it's we demonstrate as
possible for the fluid connection that's
also we call them rapid mate connectors
for a fluid in and power and we have
demonstrated the quick swap of a Model S
battery pack with four guys nothing
really automated for guys with with
wrenches and they can swap a pack in
under 10 minutes it doesn't even look
like they're working that hard when they
do it and most of the time is spent
doing all the bolts on the bottom side
it's you know there's 30 odd bolts that
they have to take out and then they drop
this whole big pack out on a cart
rolling another one shove it up their
they do a little alignment to get it
right there and then slam it home and
bolt it in place and they can do it
pretty quick but the piece that I don't
I can't wrap my head around is how do
you get a company's to organize around a
form factor yes ma'am what about I went
to her better
give their pitch and they were saying
you know what if we had four different
types of batteries yeah yeah so you
could I they might be right I very well
could be wrong it happens daily so I'm
sure that huh I could be wrong about
this one yeah that's the North America
plan how about the global long-term plan
I haven't seen maps for that I don't
know what the plan is there isn't there
any interest oh I'm sure there will be
we haven't started selling for instance
the Model S is not for sale yet in
Europe and it won't be until I finish
designing the plug that goes on the
outside of the car for the charger to go
in they use they use three-phase for all
their high power loads in Europe so it's
a different form factor for the plug and
I haven't finished the design for that
specific actually read somewhere that if
you can swap for battery packs in the
batteries can be leased instead of god
yes so you know that late that would be
the cause right that would be a big deal
to that would I think that would offset
a lot of the initial cost of the vehicle
so yeah some of you figure that out cuz
I got a way to figure that out oh I just
had another question go ahead why the
bench pressure for these super chargers
are you guys looking at all into like
vehicle to grid stuff or is that not oh
um we have a couple of guys who have
been looking at that stuff I I don't
know what the status of that work is
does seem like there's a lot of
potential there in this could be like
one of those things where there isn't an
awesome grid storage system out there
yet because it's just too expensive so
far but oh look people are putting these
big battery packs in cars and they're
willing to pay the big bucks for them so
yes the the grid storage this this could
be how you make that all work but but of
course
all these things are you know there's
electronic communication one of the one
of the things that comes with the
electric vehicle is you have a
communication to the battery you can
talk to you can't ask it how often it
gets used how much it gets used what its
current state of charge is whether it
likes chocolate or vanilla anything it
knows all that stuff and in fact the
Tesla vehicles if you enable it Tesla
knows all the stuff about your battery
pack too because we have communications
with all those things wirelessly so you
really could say gosh two to four
o'clock is PQ's everybody send your
power the other way for a couple hours
and the battery packs could certainly
handle the cycling one of the I think
there's those challenges of knowing you
know obviously the owner of the vehicle
has to enable that and put some minimum
amount of charge they want their battery
when they come out of their office at
the end of the day to get home and so
there's a bunch of issues around that
but I think they could take the cycling
and as long as you are careful about
that cycling you get a lot of life out
of those battery packs so I've heard
stories about you know the number of the
cycle life of these packs of this
particular cell type really about if you
treat them well like you only charge
them to like sixty or seventy percent
full you don't actually charge them all
the way to max all the time you don't
take them down to the bottom all the
time they actually will take tens of
thousands of charge cycles it's really
it's really this top to bottom cycling
that just is beats the heck out of them
yes sir let's the unleash plan which is
better ego I'm sorry what's the
angeleyes plan so mostly recycling it's
an illuminant closure the the battery
the cells themselves are actually
recyclable and you can recycle them at a
profit there they are the cells are
Rojas complying
there's no heavy metals or real
hazardous wastes in them play just grind
them up and they can recycle them yes
sir sorry back to the remove a removable
battery question so it can be done with
the Roadster but would wouldn't be
feasible for future models to to design
it in such a way so that it's easier to
exchange battery yeah yeah you certainly
could do it with the model s and and I'm
i wouldn't say i'm not saying it
couldn't technically be done i think
there's I think you really could right
now we've got like 30 fasteners to hold
the thing in but obviously if you design
another system for attaching the pack
which could be a champ that's not
already right it's not a high priority
is no place to swap those packs out it's
not in our business model the leasing
thing would be an obvious thing to do
but then you're you know what do you buy
and what's the state all I think that
the challenges around the business of
making that work are just not something
that Tesla is ready to get into yet
could be for all I know they'll announce
next week that they're in that business
but I I I don't imagine that being the
case we got so many other issues to deal
with the other question yeah 50 grand is
Tesla taking a leaf out of like the
solar the revolution that's happening
the solar financing
like bringing down the cost of solar
installation by just let me pay for the
energy into the pain for the solar
panels in the first place it's Tesla
kind of sort of like going to me where
they would help the customers find and
so there's like a wide range of adoption
and not only just high-end customers who
are buying this not that I've heard of I
could certainly imagine that sort of
thing happening in the future but it's
not where we're at yet I think they're
they'd still like to turn a profit first
and yeah we're not running in the red
yet so I mean we're not running in the
black yet scuze me so yeah we got a ways
to go the topic um so to Tesla bread
through a lot of cash with the roadster
and with the day going public and the
DoD infusion um is there 0 projected a
time frame where you're going to be in
the black or or if not on how long do
you think another yeah there is
definitely a projected time for when we
will be running in the black I honestly
don't know what that is because I didn't
think to look it up and if I the only
data that I would ever be able to give
you would be stuff that would be readily
available online anyway so if I knew
anything different I couldn't tell you
and I don't so I can't tell you anything
different but yeah it's I think at some
point when the you know our goal is to
hit a production rate of about 20,000
vehicles per year model s and that's and
it's some point in their we must we must
start running in the black I don't at
some point below 20,000 vehicles per
year we must start running in the black
I'm sure they just released a relief of
press release about that at the
quarterly earnings
I think I think it was 200 a week just
10,000 I think that was the number there
was a we had a goal we were trying to
hit some threshold and I kind of think
it was 200 a week I honestly don't
remember if you I'd have to look at the
press release anything else yes sir yeah
you can defer this one of your business
people as you'd like to is looking at
sales of electric vehicles and plugins
and if you know you took under 10,000 is
a year we haven't made a dent in the
tons of carbon atmosphere yet what is it
going to take to really make all this
stuff take off is it the battery issue
that you talked about earlier is it
battery technology that it caused how do
we get to where there's hundreds of
thousands a year of introduced not just
a Tesla that I mean industry right so
I'm definitely not the business guy to
ask that question my my personal
engineering perspective is it's all
about the cost you know to me there's
there's cost first volume second you
know lugging around whatever it is a
thousand or 500 kilos of battery payload
is is too much and paying twenty or
thirty thousand dollars for battery pack
is too much so until those numbers
really come down I wouldn't imagine
we'll see a really big that would but
that's pure personal speculation
let's take our speakers
you